Then there's the example of rats,
which I love.
This is Jaak Panksepp work,
and he wrote a book called affective
neuroscience,
would I,
which I would highly,
highly recommend.
I have a list of readings,
recommended readings on my website.
It's a brilliant book and he's a
brilliant psychologist,
really one of the top top psychologist
as far as I'm concerned,
both theoretically and experimentally,
a real genius.
He's the guy who discovered that rats
laugh when you tickle them.
They loud laugh ultrasonically,
so you can't actually hear them,
but if you record it and slow it down,
then you can hear them giggling away
when you tickle them with an eraser,
which is sort of like their mother's
tongue.
It's often what lab people use as a
substitute for the licking of the little
wrapped by the mother.
So,
so,
and he discovered the place circuit and
in mammals,
which is like a major deal,
right?
He should get a Nobel prize for that.
That's a big deal to discover an entire
motivational circuit whose existence no
one had really predicted,
you know,
apart from the fact that obviously
mammals play and uh,
even lizards,
maybe some of the more social lizards
seemed to play,
you know,
so anyhow,
but panksepp observed,
I think this is a brilliant piece of
science,
is that first of all,
juvenile male routes in particular,
like too rough and tumble play.
They like to wrestle and they actually
pin each other just like little kids do.
Or like adult wrestlers do.
They pin their shoulders down and that
basically means you win.
And so,
okay,
so that's pretty cool.
But what's even cooler,
I think while there's three things,
one is the rats will work for an
opportunity to get into an arena where
they know that play might occur.
And so that's one of the scientific ways
of testing in animals motivation,
right?
So imagine you have a starving wrath and
it knows that it's got food down the end
of a corridor.
You can put a little spring on its tail
and measure how hard it pulls and that
gives you an indication of it's
motivational force.
Now imagine the starving rat that's
trying to get to some food and you have
a little spring on his tail and you
walked in some cat odor,
so now that route is starving and wants
to get out of there.
He's going to try to pull even farther
towards the food,
so getting away plus getting forward are
separate motivational systems and if you
can add them together,
it's real potent and part of the reason
why in the future authoring exercise
that you guys are going to do as the
class progresses,
you're asked to outline the place you'd
like to end up,
which is your desired future,
and also the place that you could end up
if you let everything fall apart is so
that your anxiety chases you and your
approach systems pull you forward.
You're maximally motivated,
dead,
and it's important because otherwise you
can be afraid of pursuing the things
that you want to pursue.
Right?
And that's very common and so then the
fear inhibits you as the promise pulls
you forward,
but it makes you weak because you're
afraid.
You want to get your fear behind you,
pushing you,
and so what you want to be as afraid,
more afraid of not pursuing your goals
than you are of pursuing them.
It's very,
very helpful.
And lots of times in life,
and this is something really worth
knowing,
you know,
this is one of the advantages to being
an tournament's adult,
is you don't get to pick the best thing.
You get to pick your poison.
You have two bad choices and you get to
pick which one you're willing to suffer
through.
And every choice has a bit of that
element in it.
And so if you know that,
it's really freeing because otherwise
you torture yourself by thinking,
well,
maybe there's a good solution to this.
You know,
compared to the bad solution.
It's like,
Nah,
sometimes there's just risky solution,
one and risky solution to.
And sometimes both of them are really
bad,
but you at least get to pick which one
you're willing to suffer through.
And that's,
that actually makes quite a bit of
difference because you're also facing it
voluntarily then instead of it chasing
you.
And that is an entire different entirely
different psychophysiological response.
Challenge versus threat.
It's not the same even if the magnitude
of the problem is the same.
And so putting yourself in a
challenging,
let's call it mind frame,
you can't just do that by magic.
Putting yourself in a challenging
mindframe is much,
much easier on you psychophysiological
because you don't produce,
you don't go into the generalized stress
response to the same degree and you're
activating your exploratory and seeking
systems which are dopaminergic,
we mediated and that involved positive
emotion.
So if you can face something voluntarily
rather than having to chase you,
it's way better for you cycle
physiologically.
So that's partly why it's worthwhile to
go find the dragon in its layer instead
of waiting for it to come and eat you.
So and especially when you also add the
idea that if you go find the dragon in
it's layer,
you might find it when it's a baby
instead of a full fledged bloody
monster.
That is definitely going to take you
down
really.